[Music]
hello hi everyone so thank you for
coming in such great numbers to this
tensorflow session
apologies is quite late in the afternoon
I will need all your brains for this
session because to today I want with you
to build a neural network so now I don't
need your brains to build in your no
brain surgery in this session but it's
another crash course to get developers
up to speed on machine learning and deep
learning and neural networks so I need
all your attention the data set we will
be using is a very classical one it's
this one here handwritten digits
academia has been working on these data
sets for the past 20 years so you should
go to the website but it's hosted you
will actually see 20 years of research
papers and that's what we will do
together today will will go on this data
set trying to build a network that
recognizes this angers and digits from
the simplest possible Network all the
way to 99% accuracy so let's start just
a question beforehand who has done some
work with a neural networks before oh
well ok quite a few people so feel free
to help me and I hope this will not be
too basic for you and I hope it will at
least be a good introduction to
tensorflow but if you have never done
anything with neural network networks
that's fine and I will explain
everything from the start so this is the
simplest possible neural network we can
imagine to recognize our handwritten
digits so the digits they come as 28 by
28 pixel images and the first thing we
do is that we flatten all those pixels
into one big vector of pixels and these
will be our inputs now we will use
exactly ten neurons
the newest are the white circles what a
neuron does is always the same thing a
neuron does a weighted sum of all of its
inputs here the pixels it adds another
constant that is called a bias that's
just an additional degree of freedom and
then it will feed this sum through an
activation function and that is just a
function number in transform number out
we will see several of those activation
functions and the one thing they have in
common in neural networks is that they
are non linear so why 10 neurons well
simply because we are classifying those
digits in 10 categories we are trying to
recognize a zero or one that you want
Illinois so what you are hoping for here
is that one of those neurons will light
up and tell us with a very strong output
that I have recognized here an 8 all
right and for that since this is a
classification problem we are going to
use a very specific activation function
one that ball researcher tells fellows
works really well on classification
problems it's called softmax and it's
simply the explore an exponential
normalized so what you do is that you
you make all those weighted sums then
you elevate that to the exponential and
once you have your 10 Exponential's you
can compute the norm of this vector and
divided by its norm so that you get
values between 0 and 1 and those values
you will be able to interpret them as
probabilities probabilities of this
being to an 801 or something else you
will be asking which norm any norm
doesn't matter the length of the vector
you pick your your your favorite norm
there are several usually for softmax we
use L 1 but L 2 which is the Euclidean
norm would work just as well so what
does soft maggots do actually you see
it's an exponential so it's very steeply
increasing function it will pull the
data support
increase the differences and when you
divide all of that when you normalize
the whole vector you usually end up with
one of the values being very close to
one and all the other values being very
close to the zero so it's a way of
pulling the winner out of top without
actually destroying the the information
all right so now we need to formalize
this using a matrix multiply I will
remind you of what a matrix multiply is
but we will do it not for one image we
are going to do this for a batch of the
100 images at a time so what I have here
in my matrix is 100 images one image per
line
the images are flattened all the pixels
on one line so I take my matrix of
weight for the time being I don't know
what these weights are just weight so
I'm doing weight itself and I start the
matrix multiplication so I do a weighted
sum of all the pixels of the first image
it is and then if I continue this matrix
multiply using the second column of
weights I get a weighted sum of all the
pixels of the first image for the second
neuron and then for the third neuron and
the fourth and so on what is left is to
add the biases just an additional
constants again we don't know what it is
only and there is one bias per neuron
that's why we have ten biases and now if
I continue this matrix multiply I'm
going to obtain these wicked sums for
the second image and the third image and
so on until I have processed all my
images and I would like to write this as
a single formula there you see there is
a problem x times W you know that's a
matrix of ten columns by 100 images and
I have only ten biases I constantly add
them together while nevermind
we will redefine addition and it's okay
if everybody accepts it
and actually people have already
accepted it it's called a broadcasting
ad and that's the way you do additions
in numpy for instance which is the
numerical library for or for bison the
way of broadcasting ad works is that if
you are trying to add two things which
don't match not the same dimensions you
can't do the addition you try to
replicate the small one as much as
needed to make the sizes match and then
you do the addition that's exactly what
we need to do here we have only those
ten biases so it's the same biases on
all the lines
we just need to replicate this bias
vector on all the lines and that's
exactly what this generalized
broadcasting ad does so we will just
write it as a plus and this is where I
wanted to get to this I want you to
remember this as the formula describing
one layer in a neural network so let's
go through this again in X we have a
batch of images 100 images all the
pixels on one line in W we have all our
weights for the ten neurons all the ways
in in the in the system x times W are
all all of our wicked sums we have the
biases and then we feed this through our
activation function in this case softmax
the way it works is line by line line by
line we take the ten values elevate them
to the exponential normalized line next
line ten values elevate them to the
exponential normalized line and so on so
what we get in the output is for each
image ten values which look like
probabilities and which are our
predictions so of course we still don't
know what those weights and biases are
and that's whether the trick is in
neural networks we are going to train
this neural network to actually figure
out the correct weights and biases by
itself well this is how you write this
in tensor flow
you see not that is different okay 10
Central has this n n library for neural
network which has all sorts of very
useful functions for neural networks for
example softmax and so on so let's go
train when you train
you've got images but you know what
those images are so your network if you
initialize your waiting biases at random
value and your network will output some
probability since you know what this
image is you can tell it that it's not
this it should be that so that is what
that is it is called a one hot encoded
vector it's very not very fancy way of
encoding numbers basically here our
numbers from 0 to 9 we encode them as 10
bits all at 0 and just one of them is 1
at the index of the number we want to
encode here are 6 why well because then
it's in the same shape as our prediction
and we can compute a difference the
distance between those two so again many
ways of computing distances the
Euclidean distance the normal distance
sum of differences squared would work
not a problem but scientists tell us
that for classification problems this
distance to cross entropy works slightly
better so we'll use this how does it
work it's the Sun across the vectors of
the values on the top multiplied by the
logarithms of the values on the bottom
and then we add a minus sign because all
the values on the bottom are less than 1
so all the logarithms are negative so
that's the distance and of course we
will tell the system to minimize the
distance between what it thinks is the
truth and what we know to be true so
this will call our error function and
the training will be guided by an effort
to minimize the error function let's
think of this work in practice
so in this little visualization I'm
showing you over there
my training images receipts training so
you see this batches of 100 training
images being set into the system on a
white background you have the images
that have been already correctly
recognized by the system on a red
background images that are still missed
so then only in the middle graph you see
our error function computed both on the
training data set and we also can't
decide a set of images which we have
never seen during training for testing
of course if you want to test the
real-world performance of your neural
network you have to do this on a set of
images which you have never seen during
training so here we have 60,000 training
images and I set aside 10,000 test
images which you see in the bottom graph
over there they're a bit small you see
only 1000 of them here so imagine there
are nine more screens of pictures like
that but I sorted all the badly
recognized one at the top so you see all
the ones that have been badly recognized
and below are nine screens of correctly
recognized images here are two mm rounds
of training so that a little scale on
the side here it shows you that it's
already capable of recognizing 92
percent of other images with this very
simple model just and neurons nothing
else and that's what you get upon the
top graph the accuracies graphs as well
that's simply the percentage of
correctly recognized images both on
tests and training data so what else do
we have where we have our weights and
biases those two diagrams are simply
percentiles so it shows you the spread
of all the weights and biases and that's
just useful to see that
they are moving they both started at
zero and they took some values for the
weights between one and minus one for
biasing between 2 and minus 2 it's
helpful to keep an eye on those diagrams
and see that we are not diverging
completely so that's the training
algorithm you give it training images
gives you a prediction you compute the
distance between the prediction and what
you know to be true you use that
distance as an error function to guide a
mechanism that will drive the error down
by modifying weights analysis so now
let's write this in tensor flow and I'll
get more explicit about exactly how this
training works so we need to write this
integral so the first thing you do in
tensor flow is defined variables and
placeholders the variable is a degree of
freedom of our system something we are
asking 10 to the flow to compute for us
through training so in our case those
are our weights and biases and we will
need to feed in training data so for
this data that will be set in at
training time we define a placeholder
you see here X X is a placeholder for
our our training images let's look at
the shaping brackets what you have is
the shape of this multi-dimensional
matrix which we call a tensor so the
first dimension is is none it says I
don't know yet this will be the number
of images in a batch this will be
determined as training training time you
forgive if we give 100 images this will
be 100 then 28 by 28 is the size of our
images and 1 is the number of values per
pixel that's not useful at all because
we are handling grayscale images I just
put it there in
you wanted to handle color images that
would be three three values for six per
pixel so okay we have our placeholders
we have our variables now we are ready
to write our model so that line you see
on the top is our model it's what we
have determined to be the line
representing one layer of the neural
network the only change is that reshape
operation you remember our images they
come in as 28 by 28 pixel images and we
want to flatten them as one big sector
of pixels so that's what the reshape
does 784 is 28 by 28 it's all the pixels
in one line all right I need a second
place holder for the known answers the
labels of my training images labels like
this is a 1 this is a 0 this is a 7 this
is a 5 and now that I have my
predictions in my no labels I'm ready to
compute my error function which is the
cross-entropy
using the formula we've seen before so
some across the vector of the elements
of the labels multiplied by elements of
the logarithm of the projections so now
I have my error function what do I do
with it what you have on the bottom I
don't I won't go into that that is
simply the computation of the percentage
of correctly recognized images you can
skip that ok now we get to the actual
heart of what tensorflow will do for you
so we have our error function we take an
optimizer there is a full library of
them there here they have different
characteristics and we ask the optimizer
to minimize our error function so what
is this going to do this is going when
you do this tensorflow takes you an
error function and compute the partial
derivatives of that error function so
that relatively took all the way and all
the biases in the system that's a big
vector because there are lots of weights
and lots of biases how many
w the wait is a drive variable of almost
8,000 values so this vector we get
mathematically is called a gradient and
the gradient has one nice property who
knows what is the nice property of the
gradient each points yes what it almost
it points up we had a minus sign it
points down exactly down in which space
we are in the space of all the weights
and endures all the variables and the
function we are computing is our error
function so when we say down in this
space it means it gives us a direction
in a direction in the space of wages and
n biases into which to go to modify our
weights and biases in order to make our
error function smaller so that is the
training you compute this gradient it
gives you an arrow you take a little
step along this arrow well you are in
the space of weights and biases so
taking a little setting to modify your
weights and biases by this little Delta
and you get into location where the
error is now smaller well fantastic
that's exactly what you want then you
repeat this using a second batch of
training images and again using the
third batch of training images and so on
so it's called gradient descent because
you follow the gradient to head down and
so we are ready to write our training
loop there is one more thing I need to
explain to you about tensor flow
tensorflow has a deferred execution
model so everything we wrote up to now
all the TF dot something here commands
there's not actually when that is
executed it doesn't produce values it
builds a graph of computation graph in
memory why is that important well first
of all
this derivation trick here the
computation of the gradient that is
actually a formal derivation tensorflow
takes the formula that you needed to
define your error function and there's a
formal derivation on it so it needs to
know the full graph of how you have you
how you computed this to do this formal
derivation and the second thing is for
use this graph for is that end result is
built for distributed computing and
there as well to distribute a graph on
multiple machine it helps to know what
the graph is okay but it means so this
is all very useful but it means for us
that we we have to go through an
additional loop to actually get values
from our computation the way you do this
in ten to the flow is that you define a
session and then in this session you
call session dot run on one edge of your
computation graph and of course for this
2m and that that will give you actual
values but of course for this to work
you have to fill in all the placeholders
that you have defined now with real
values so for this to work I will need
to fill in the training images and the
training labels for which I have defined
placeholders and the syntax is simply
the trained data dictionary there you
see the keys of the Dex dictionary x and
y underscore are the placeholders that I
have defined and then I call session the
run on my training step I pass in this
training data and that is where the
actual magic happens
just rely on what is this training step
well it's what you got when you asked
the optimizer to minimize your error
function so the training step when
executed is actually what computes this
gradient using the current batch of
images training images and labels and
follows it a little to modify the
weights and biases and end up with
better ways and biases
I said a little I come back to this what
is that learning a race over there well
I can't make a big step along the
gradient why not
imagine you're in the mountains you know
we're down is we have senses for that we
don't know to derive anything we know
we're down it and you want to reach the
bottom of the valley now if every step
you made is a 10-mile step you will
probably be jumping from one side of the
valley to the other without ever
reaching the bottom so if you want to
reach the bottom even if you know we're
down is you have to make small steps
steps in that direction and then you
will reach the bottom so the same here
when we compute this gradient we
multiple we multiplied by this very
small value so as to take small steps
and be sure that we're not jumping from
one side of the valley to the other all
right so let's finish our training
basically in a loop we load a batch of
100 training images and labels we run
this training step which adjusts our
weights and biases and we repeat all the
rest of the stuff on the bottom it's
just for display I'm computing the
accuracy and the cross-entropy
on my training data and again on my test
data so that I can show you four curves
over there it is just for display that
has nothing to do with the training
itself all right so that was it that's
the entire code here on one slide let's
go through this again at the beginning
you define variables for everything that
you want tensorflow to compute for you
so here are our weights and biases you
define placeholders for everything that
you will be feeding during the training
mainly our images and our training
labels then you define your model
your model gives you predictions you can
compare those predictions with your
known labels compare a distance between
the two which is the cross entropy here
and use that as an error function so you
pick an optimizer and you RC optimizer
to minimize your error function that
gives all the gradients and all that it
gives you a training set and now in a
loop you load a batch of images you're
on your training set you load a batch of
images and labels you're on your
training set and you do this in a loop
and hoping this will converge literally
it does as you see here it did converge
and with this approach we got 92%
accuracy smaller recaps of all the
ingredients we put in our pops so far we
have a softmax activation function we
have the cross entropy as an error
function and we did this mini batching
saying where we trained one 100 images
at a time do one step and then load
another batch of images so he's 92%
accuracy good now
horrible imagine you're actually using
this in production I don't know in the
post office you're you're decoding zip
codes 98 92 percent out of 100 digits
you have 8 bad values no not usable in
production forget it so how do we fix it
well deep learning will go deep you can
just stack those layers how do how do we
do that well it's very simple look at
the top layer of neurons it does what we
just did it computes a weighted sums of
pixels but we can just as easily add a
second light that will compute weighted
sums of the outputs of the first layer
and that's how you stack layers to
produce a deep neural network now we are
going to change our activation function
we keep softmax for the output layer
because softmax has these nice
properties of pulling a winner apart and
producing numbers between zero and one
but for the rest we use a very classical
oxidation function in neural networks is
called the sigmoid and it's basically
the simplest possible continuous
function that goes from zero to one okay
all right let's write this model so we
have now one set of weights and one set
of biases per layer that's why we use c5
Ayers here and our model will actually
look very familiar to you look at the
first line it's exactly what we have
seen before for one layer of a neural
network now what we do with the output
y1 is that we use it as the input in the
second line and so on we change those
it's just that on the last line the
activation function we use is the
softmax so that's all the changes we did
and we can try to run this again so this
one run run run and let's comment
well I don't like this slope here should
be shooting up really sharp it's a big
flow actually I have a solution for that
III lied to you what I said that the
sigmoid was the most widely used
activation function that was true in the
past and today people invented a new
activation function which is called the
Rayleigh and this is irrelevant simpler
it's just zero for all negative values
and identity for all positive values now
this actually works better it has lots
of advantages why does it work better we
don't know people tried it it works
better I'm being honest here if you had
a researcher here he would fill your
head with equations and prove it but he
would have done those equations after
the fact people already tried it it
worked better actually they got
inspiration from biology it is said I
don't think it is true but I heard that
the sigmoid was the preferred model of
biologists for our actual biological
neurons and that today biologist thinks
the thing that neurons in our head work
more like this and the guys in computer
science got inspiration from that pride
it works better how better well this is
just the beginning of the training this
is what we get with our sigmoids just
300 iterations so that's just the
beginning and this is what we get from
Raley's well I prefer this each the
accuracy chutes are really sharp the
cross-entropy goes down really sharp
it's much faster and actually here on
this very single problem the sigmoid
would have recovered it's not an issue
but in very deep networks sometimes with
the Sigma's you don't converge at all
and and the Rayleigh solves that problem
to some extent
so the renovating is for most of our
issues okay so now let's train let's do
this for ten thousand iterations side
layers look at that
ninety-eight percent accuracy first of
all oh yeah we went from 92 to 98 just
by adding layers that's fantastic but
look at those curves but all messy what
is all this noise well when you see
noise like that it means that you are
going too fast you're actually jumping
from one side of the valley to the other
without correctly reaching the bottom of
your error function so we have a
solution for that but it's not just to
go slower because then you would spend
10 much ten times more time training the
solution actually is to start fast and
slow down as you as you train it's
called learning rate we can usually
educate the learning rate on an
exponential curve so yes I hear you it
sounds you know very simple why why this
little trick but let me play you the
video of what this does it's actually
quite spectacular so it's almost there
should I have the end of it on a slide
yeah that's it so this is what we had
using a fixed learning rate and just by
switching to a decaying learning rate
look it's spectacular all the noise is
gone and for the first so just with this
little trick really this is not rocket
science it's just going slightly slower
towards the end and all the noise is
gone and look at the blue curve the
training accuracy curve towards the end
is stuck at 100% so here for the first
time we built a neural network that was
capable of learning all of our training
set perfectly
it doesn't make one single mistake in
the entire training set which doesn't
mean that it's perfect in the real world
as
receipt on the training shoulder on the
test data set it has a 98% accuracy but
well it's something we got 100% at least
on the inflation alright so we still
have something that is a bit design
look at those two curves that's this is
our error function so the blue curve the
test error function that is what we
minimize okay so as expected it goes
down and the error function computed on
our test data at the beginning well it
follows that's quite nice
and then it's disconnected so this is
not completely unexpected you know we
are minimizing the training error
function that's what we are actively
minimizing we are not doing anything at
all
on the on the test side it's just a
byproduct of the way neural networks
work that the training you do on your
training data actually carries over to
your test data to the real world well it
carries over or it doesn't so as you see
here until some point it does and then
there is a disconnect it doesn't it
doesn't carry over anymore
you keep optimizing the error on the
training data but it has no positive
effect on the test performance the real
work performance anymore
so if you see curve like this you take
the textbook you look it up it's called
overfitting you you look at the
solutions they tell you over feeling you
need regularization
okay let's regular eyes what
regularization options do we have my
preferred one is called dropouts it's
it's kind of quite dramatic you shoot
the neurons no really
so this is how it works you take your
narrow network and pick a probability
let's say 50% so at each training
iteration you will shoot physically
removed from the network 50% of your
neurons
do the Tough then put them back next
iteration again randomly shoot 50% of
you in Europe of course when you test
you don't test with a half brain-dead
neural network you put all the neurons
back but that's what you do for training
so in an intensive flow there is a very
single function to do that which is
called dropout that you apply at the
output of the layer and what it simply
does that if you take the probability
and in the output of that layer it will
replace randomly some values by zeros
and small technicality it will actually
boost the remaining values
proportionally so that the average stays
constant that's it that's a technicality
so why does shooting neurons help well
first of all let's see if it helps so
let's let's try to recap all the tricks
we try to play with our neural network
this is what we had initially with our
five layers using the sigmoid as an
activation function it got the accuracy
got up to ninety seven point nine
percent using five layers so first we
replace two sigmoid by the rayleigh
activation function
you see it's faster to converge at the
beginning and we actually gained a
couple of fractions of percentage of
accuracy but we have this messy curve so
we trained slower using the exponential
learning rate in VK and we get rid of
the noise and now we are stable or above
98% accuracy but we have that weird
disconnect between the error on our test
data and the error allowed on our
training data so let us try to add
dropout this is what you get with
dropout and actually the cross entropy
function the test cross entropy function
the red one over there and on the on the
right has been largely brought under
under control you see there is still
some disconnect but it's not shooting at
as it was before that's very positive
let's look at the accuracy no
improvement actually I'm even amazed
that it hasn't gone down seeing how
brutal this technique is you should
neuron watch while you're trained let's
here I was very hopeful to get it up
no nothing we have to keep digging so
what is really overfitting
let's go beyond the simple recipe in the
textbook what over filling in a neural
network is primarily when you give it
too many degrees of freedom imagine you
have so many neurons in so many ways in
a neural network but it's somehow
feasible to simply store all the
training images in those weights and add
variables you have enough room for that
and the neural network could figure out
some cheap tricks to pattern match the
training images in what it has Ford and
just perfectly recognize your training
images because it has stored copies of
all of them well if it has enough space
to do that that would not translate to
any kind of recognition performance in
the real world and that's the trick
about neural networks you have to
constrain their degrees of freedom to
force them to generalize and mostly when
you get overfitting is because you have
too many neurons you need to get to get
that number down to force the network to
produce generalizations that will then
produce good predictions even in the
real world
so even you either you get the number of
neurons down or you apply some tricks
like drop out that is supposed to
mitigate the consequences of too many
degrees of freedom these opposites of
too many neurons if you have a very
small data sets well even if you have
only a little a small number of neurons
if the data set the training data that
is very small it can still fit easily so
that's a general truth in in a neural
networks you need big data sets for
training and then what happens here we
have a big data set sixty thousand
digits that's enough we know that we
don't have too many neurons because we
added five layers that's a bit overkill
but I tried I promise with four and
three and two and we try to drop out
which is supposed to mitigate to the
fact that you have too many neurons and
didn't do anything to the access so the
conclusion here that we come to is that
our network the way it is built is
inadequate it's not capable by by its
architecture to extract the necessary
information from our data and maybe
someone here can pinpoint something is
really stupid
we did at the beginning someone has an
idea remember we have images images with
shapes with curves and and lines and we
flattened all the pixels you know in one
big vector so all that shape information
is lost
this is terrible that's why we are
performing so badly we lost all of the
shape information so what is the
solution what people have invented a
different type of neural networks to
handle specifically images and problems
where shape is important it's called
convolutional networks
here we go back to the to the general
case of an image of the other color
image that's why it has red green and
blue components and in a convolutional
Network one neuron will still be doing
weighted sums of pixels but only a small
patch of pixels above its head only a
small patch and the next year would
again be doing a weighted sum of the
small patch of pixels above above itself
but using the same weights okay that's
the fundamental difference from what we
have seen before
the second neuron is using the same
weight as the first neuron so we are
actually taking just one set of weights
and we are scanning the image in both
directions using that set of voice and
producing weighted sums so we scan it in
both directions and we obtain one layer
of weight itself so how many weights do
we have well has many weights as we have
seen put values in that little
highlighted cube that's four times four
times three which is around 48 what 48
we had 8,000 degrees of freedom in our
simplest network with just 10 neurons
how can it work with such a drastic
reduction in the number of ways well it
won't work we need more degrees of
freedom how do we do that well we pick a
second set of weights and do this again
and we obtain a second let's call it a
channel of values using different
weights and now since those are
multi-dimensional matrices is fairly
easy to write those those two matrices
as one by simply hiding the dimension of
dimension two because we have two sets
of values and this here will be the
shape of the White Nights matrix for one
convolutional layer in in a neural
network
now we still have one problem left which
is that we need to bring the amount of
information down
at the end we still want only ten
outputs with our ten probabilities to
recognize what this number is
so traditionally this was achieved by
what we call a sub sampling layer it's I
think it's what useful to understand how
this works because it gives you a good
feeling for what this network is doing
so basically we were scanning the image
using a set of weights and during
trainings these weights will actually
specialize in some kind of shape
recognizers there will be some ways that
will become very sensitive to horizontal
lines and some ways that will become
very sensitive to vertical lines and so
on
so basically when you scan the image if
you simplify you get an output which is
mostly I see nothing I see nothing I
think nothing all I seen something I've
seen nothing I see nothing oh I've seen
something
the subsampling basically takes four of
those outputs two by two and it takes
the maximum value so it retains the
biggest signal of I seen something and
passes death down to the layer below but
actually this is a much simpler way of
you know condensing information what if
we simply play with the stripe of the
convolution instead of applying is
instead of scanning the image pixel by
pixel we scan it every two pixels we
jump by two pixels between each weighted
sum or mechanically instead of obtaining
28 by 28 output values we will say only
14 by 14 output values so we have
condensed our information and mostly
today I'm not saying this is better but
it's just simpler and mostly today
people who build convolutional networks
just use convolutional layers and play
with the with the step
to condense the information and and it's
simpler you don't have you don't need in
this way to have these sometimes
subsampling layers so this is the
network that I would like to build with
you let's go to it there is a first
convolutional layer that uses patches of
5x5 I'm reading through the w1 tensor
and we have seen the dish in this shape
the two first digits if the size of the
patch you pass the third digits is the
number of channels it's reading from the
input so he ran back to my real example
this is a grayscale image it has one
value per pixel so I'm reading one
channel of information and I will be
applying four of those patches to my
image so I obtain four channels about
the values okay now second convolutional
layer this time my stride is two so here
my outputs become planes of 14 by 14
values so let's go through it it's I'm
applying patches of four by four I'm
reading in four channels of values
because that's why our output in the
first layer and this time I'll do I will
be using eight different patches so I
will actually produce 80 different
channels of wicked cells next layer
again astride of two that's why I'm
getting down from 14 by 14 to 7 by 7
patches of 4x4 reading in 8 channels of
values because that's what I had in the
previous layer and outputting 12
channels or values this time because I
use 12 different patches and now I apply
a fully connected layer so the kind of
layer we've seen before
okay this fully connected layer I have
remember the differences in this one
each neuron does the weighted sum of all
the values okay in the little cube of
values above not just a patch all the
values in the next neuron in the fully
connected Network
does again a weighted sum of all the
values using its own ways it's not
sharing with that's the normal neural
network layer as we have seen before
and finally I apply my soft max layer
with my kenhub
alright so can you write this in tensor
flow well we need one set of weights and
biases for each layer the only
difference is that for the convolutional
layers our weights we have this will
have this specific shape that we have
seen before so two two numbers for the
filter size one number for the number of
input channels and one number for the
number of patches which corresponds to
the number of output channels that you
produce for our normal players we have
the weights and biases defined as before
and you see this truncated normal thingy
up there that's just a random okay to
complicated way of saying random so we
initialize those weights to random
values initially and now this is what
our model will look like so tensorflow
have this helpful
cons 2d function if you give it a weight
matrix and batch of images it will scan
them in both directions so it's just a
double loop to scan the image in both
directions and produce the weight itself
so we do those way sums we added bias we
feed this through an activation function
in this case the ready and that's our
outputs and again the way of stacking
these layers is to feed y1 the first
output as the input of the next layer
all right after with our three
convolutional layers we need to do a
weighted sum this time of all the values
in this 7 by 7 by 12 little cube so to
achieve that we will flatten this cube
as one big vector of value
that's what the flatten the reshape here
does and then two additional lines that
is that aligns that you should recognize
those are normal neural network layers
as we have seen before all right
and let this work so this time it like
it takes a little bit more time to to
process so I have a video you see the
accuracy is shooting a really fast I
will have to zoom and the prom is
tonight stone and percent accuracy is
actually not too far we're getting there
we're getting there how are we getting
there we're not getting there oh yeah
and so disappointed again I really
wanted to bring this to 99% accuracy
we'll have to do something more 98.9
damage that was so close all right yes
exactly
this should be your WTF moment what is
that on the cross entropy loss curve
okay let me zoom on it you see that a
disconnect do we have a solution for
this drop out yes
let's go shooting our neurons it didn't
work last time indeed this time it will
so actually what we will do here it's a
little trick it's almost a methodology
for coming up with the ideal neural
network for a given situation and what I
like doing is to restrict the degrees of
freedom until it's apparent that it's
not optimal it's hurting the performance
here I know that I can get about 90 to
99 percent so I restricted it a little
bit too much and from that point I give
it a little bit more freedom and applied
result to make sure that this additional
freedom will not result in over
and that's basically how you'll pain a
pretty optimal neural network for a
given problem so that's what I've done
here you see the patch is on a slightly
bigger 6 6 5 5 4 4 instead of 5 5 4 4
and so on and I've used a lot more
patches so 6 patches in the first layer
12 in the second layer and 24 in the
third layer instead of 4 8 and 12 and I
apply dropout in the fully connected
layer so now why not in the other layers
I tried both it's possible to apply drop
out in convolutional layers but actually
if you count the number of neurons there
there is a lot more neurons in the fully
connected layer so it's a lot more
efficient to be shooting them there I
mean you need to hurt a little bit too
much to shoot neurons where you have one
of your few them so with this let's run
this again so again the accuracy should
suffer is very fast I will have to zoom
in look welding well the 99% is and we
are above yes thank you I promise you
will get above 99 and we are actually
quite constantly above we get to 99.3%
in this time let's see what our dropout
actually did so this is what we had with
a five layer Network and already a
little bit more degrees of freedom so
more layers sorry more patches in each
layer you see we are already above 99
percent but we have this big you know
disconnect between the tests and the
training cross entropy later the slide
result boom the test cross entropy
function is brought in under control
it's not shooting up as much and look
this time we actually had a problem in
this
with just applying the result we got
two-tenths of a percent more accuracy
and here we're sure we win we are
fighting on for the last percent between
99 and 100 so getting to 10th is
enormous with just a little trick
alright so there we have it we built
this network and brought it all the way
to 99% accuracy the plates nodes just
social justice summary and to finish so
this was mostly about tensor flow we
also have a couple of three trained
api's which you can use Justin a PRS if
your problem is standard enough to fit
into one of those clouds Asian cloud
speech natural language or translate API
and if you want to run your tensor flow
jobs in the clouds we also have this
cloud ml engine service that allows you
to execute your tensor flow jobs in the
cloud for training and what is even more
important with just a click of a button
you can take a train model and push it
to production behind an API and start
serving predictions from the model in
the cloud so there that's I think that's
a little technical detail but from an
engineering perspective it's quite
significant that you have a very easy
way of pushing something to product
thank you you have the code on github
and this slide deck is freely available
at that URL and with that we have five
minutes for questions if you have any
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]